so cool to learn that why is it say it
here why do they tell us who's in a
movie because it might sell it I know
that would have been so cool do your job
he's in this movie we just learned about
Pedro B we didn't know this moment what
is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we have come back to finish off
the franchise equalizer two get ready
for koi genre and Greg Alba to ruin this
movie
because we're gonna talk over it because
otherwise we're watching in silence but
you're gonna comment anyway some people
are like oh this is like movie
commentary as well as reaction now we're
gonna do triple the commentary for the
2.5 percent that hit the dislike button
we might miss more dialogue making jokes
that you hate just working fun back at
the few yeah my Nord because most of you
loved it but the ones that didn't we
read those comments that was my first
time re-watching McCoy that was his
first time reacting and watching ever
and this one we're going both in rand's
bacon anyway guys leave a like because
we're gonna be doing this as always you
can catch our full-length ratchet and
watch along We sync up with your own
copy of The Equalizer too we are
watching this off Hulu cover several
things exclusively over the reaction
highlights of watchalongs included you
excited uh he's got hair this time so
I'm reluctant but still in I know I love
I trust it I'm gonna prefer the bald
look yeah but that was just a still
that's true a lot of people love this
one it has less of an impact negatively
than people said about Kung Fu 3 and we
both landed well in kung fu 3. I don't
know anything about it I've not seen it
have not seen her trailer either
thank you
book 100 again great like between the
world and me is gonna set up so much I
can feel it hot water please
excuse me
playing the fool I don't trust his guess
my brother you say you can find whatever
you wish in Turkey how about a man who
kidnapped his own daughter and took her
away from her American mother yes you
can find that in Turkey maybe next year
I would give him a chance to stop to
think about the worst thing that could
ever happen to him
oh he's gonna go for the strike
what's your watch
yes
hell yeah they're two kinds of pain in
this world
pain that hurts pain that alters bacon
Sun City Dixon
thank you
yeah I love him always giving someone a
chance like that's such a good narrative
through line my
State Department doesn't know a thing
about it Grace just that 45 minutes ago
someone delivered your daughter to the
desk downstairs I'd say things got
equalized this divorce is equal
foreign
posters everywhere with that hat
he's a Lyft driver that's amazing uh how
about that though it's not easy getting
in and out copy center little
this is Denzel's first sequel huh other
than Glory too I mean obviously yeah
okay thank you for this interview and
opportunity thank you for this
opportunity
this is like a reverse on those horror
movies that every screenwriter pitches a
Lyft driver who's like a serial killer
you know this guy just helps people he
just goes around wanting to help
we hit it
correct
first door
yes sir
I'll be there to pick you up when you
get back I hope that is the end of the
movie I would love that same guy that
would be a very short time he served in
Iraq
just a week bro unless this movie's fans
like a long period of time and a
nine-day tour left you something
upstairs did you you're coming to the
bathroom yes I'm coming plates and
napkins and forks I like how he's more
joyous he's got a whole new life serves
a purpose he feels vengeful
so I said
although this guy just looks oh my God
oh my God he's just like confused this
whole time he's not even like scared
no threat just gives Celtics just oh I
mean business
I got your name on a piece of paper in
my pocket American
stop talking your son's gonna be home
any second yeah
open your mouth no no open your mouth oh
damn that is Sinister
[Music]
this movie knows how to paint villain
these both these movies man that was
what a minute and he's like the worst
yeah
ordered a book last week oh oh uh yeah
he's a Lyft driver but doesn't doesn't
have Amazon
2018. come on
oh she knows Secret
oh he's just checking in on her
came in yesterday thank you what number
last one 100. sign is down oh it changes
circumstances not going anywhere now
holes I feel like if I was a mom I'd
still kind of want to know in case like
what if my daughter gets taken away from
me like some closure yeah I do like the
added pep and Denzel of like him feeling
Vindicated what he's doing now that I
know Patriots and this I just keep
waiting for him to show up
good guy or bad guy what do you think I
think he's totally a bad guy yeah
go get in her apartment
oh man
if you heard a woman he is going to come
after you on the Lyft driver that you
called take home your girlfriend not a
girlfriend man just an intern the uh
credit card was invalid let you hang
with us because your daddy's a client
you [__] up the first thing
I heard about these I've never seen one
before yeah well now you have look pay
yourself whatever and uh give yourself a
nice tip
I'm a bad guy
took it to Mass General to pumping a
stomach as we speak what's her name you
don't know do you
oh I'm gonna need your cameras cell
phones anything you might have used to
record what you did to her record damn
foreign
Score says he's The Equalizer
he knocked on the wrong door tonight
pops
oh my god with the
metal card
s oh
[Music]
what Merc just to a one
big deal
towards
call 9-1-1 you tell them the truth about
what happened in there tonight her name
is Amy give me your left hand
give me your left hand I like this yeah
just the darkness in him I expect the
five-star rating you understand not for
me though for who Amy that's right Amy
full-blown Darkness vigilante I love it
I know it's awesome and like making them
so deserving of his [__] scorn in
like seconds
this is how he's earned all his
five-star ratings breaking hands leave
one man alive
write me and tip me I just love how he
just resorts to kill him he's always got
an outlet like a rat to kill him cause
he's over he's like he's got us the time
stamps as in the tip
I can smell you
hey oh he's got a new book out maybe I
should read in it yeah politics of Nepal
prior to the 1816 sigali treaty is your
bag definitely friendship has its limits
get expression I like that clever I
realized that I didn't have any clothes
left that Vivian had ever seen I don't
know what happened to those purple
shirts that you used to buy and and I
put one on that she like wow this is
interesting mm-hmm go home huh make a
piece of it is what Vivian would have
wanted but we need equalizer three yeah
we can't find peace so screw Vivian's
wishes sorry sorry Vivian but you're
dead you can't leave Boston
yeah like the first one was slowly
revealing who he was and now that we
know who he is we just get a zero in and
it's like diving deeper into details and
personal and yeah that's pretty cool and
the immediacy of things because the
sequel we already know so the villains
are immediately like the worst and it's
very cool way to do a sequel
oh what on his Turf hey Mr McCall maybe
you could find out who did this the
Fatima's Garden kids well a bunch of
kids are about to get murdered in 30
seconds no Second Chances
[Laughter]
hey it's the kid from American Saga
Wu-Tang he plays Rizza oh that's cool
he's so good dude this kid's so talented
you should let somebody else do this
then like who you know they got a they
got painting companies around here I
know they charge six seven hundred
dollars to do the job I know that's
said I'll do this for 350.
I'm an artist man I go to Bridgeview us
why aren't you in school I don't be
doing all them everyday classes
and it takes talent to make money but it
takes brains to keep it miles
I wish Denzel was my dad he's just a
good dad from that one second tell he's
good because most of the time a scene
like that I would go sounds like that's
the actor's auditions yeah and instead
you're like he's keeping up with Denzel
and he's interesting and charismatic
yeah he's very believable yeah I've been
thinking about shawarfield and uh
calibrating uh 250 I take care of all of
this for you
you can only work on it after school
curse what time you get out three for
two okay after school 3 15 deal cash all
right okay cash
there he is clean cut Pedro yeah
caliber did work for us and when
something occurs to one of ours oh he's
corrupt I think he might be a good guy I
don't know why is he second credited
maybe because it's Pedro
today I broke a personal best successive
days alive
it's great that's
portrait of my sister Magna my sister
marked then I was sent to different
camps and I see somebody auctioning my
painting I got here the proof no record
no bill of sales he just keeps going
back to court to hear the same thing get
in there get in there
do me a favor let's see what you can
find out yeah oh another dinner then
I'm worried she's gonna die I'm very
worried she's more likable more screen
time yeah
sell records you'll have them later
today
I'm gonna go bad guys still I'm gonna
say good guy but he gets in the way of
Denzel doing his job because he's by the
book
I don't know she must have made the
judge
pay any attention to me oh this poor guy
my uncle commissioned the portrait my
little brother she'd say my Sammy I
could never protect her to lose her
twice this old guy is great he's so good
he's great yeah stayed on Calvert's hard
drive just came in no we'll talk about
it on the plane I want to get out of
here as soon as we can run some serious
Buzz down yeah hold on let's see I don't
trust this elevator ride about to get
winter soldiered I see you downstairs at
six you got it and how about some of
that delicious Belgian chocolate you're
always talking about oh you're not
getting on the plane
yes I'm going back out
oh no it's gonna happen isn't it we're
gonna we're gonna lose Pedro already no
her oh yeah she's gone this is it
those two people we met
no
no this time she got too close
equalizing is personal
oh great
yeah
let her have a shot
[Music]
that's
lucious she's going for it man a castle
this entire building
okay how much it's becoming fences
it's the Hat Man
soon he's going to start really
criticizing this gun
angry or angry
hey Brian
yeah listen I'm I'm reading your book
right now and I can't believe you
somebody's going to Belgium
yo Mr McCoy you good are yo Mr McCall
oh he even left this book The pacing of
this one's interesting is there's a lot
more atmosphere yeah they use the their
environments a lot more and just let
that kind of be the the mood and there's
more subplots like there's a lot like
the old man him the kid like there's a
lot more going on it's sort of
existentialism quality like the
questioning of purpose of life
and the the first book is between me and
the world which is like
I mean he can't attend this right he's
supposed to be dead oh yeah might be a
tell Pedro totally stuck them on her you
think he's a bad guy thousand percent
you might be rapid help you're not
yeah but in these hotels these robberies
but she never wore any jewelry except
for this
they're working with Interpol promised
to find whoever it was it's a sorrowful
experience man I thought that was really
interesting
the way he receives this is a very
interesting action franchise it really
is because there's so much dramatic heft
in these films and most people just talk
about like the action scenes but this is
a real character
yeah there's like a other than you know
obvious death to grieve there is a
grievance tone throughout this whole
movie yeah like from beginning to end
very sorrowful yep it's like all even
the subplots deal a lot with loss and
relax
yeah yeah even the person with the
painting you know yeah he can't do you
can't accept it
people don't like when we make
commentary 2.5 excuse us
foreign
so many bad people we've met a lot of
like there's a lot more disparate
villainy in this or maybe it's not so
I'm sure it'll it'll congeal
is anyone else like super fascinated by
this franchise because he's committed so
much violence but then it's so
interesting to see this moment work
because of someone he loves he can't he
can't and the violence is jarring now
like they shot it so I'm more repulsed
by it yeah that was really it was
disturbing it was a disturbing scene
you got fat Dave
he looks deep big he does because we're
so used to him grizzled yeah
you're dead
oh wow I was in the same Lobby when that
bomb went off Susan she knew how was
your partner for seven years back I
never kept anything from you ah okay you
still at the beach not a long time well
they got me that cabin
take the wife and kids up a couple times
a year if you have any of it it is so
cool seeing them together it is yeah
yeah I think he's a bad guy now but it's
great to see it yeah
definitely a bad guy
she never pushed a button today oh it's
losing on the elevator she never pushed
the floor number I checked all the video
Backpackers got on first oh he looks
nervous a couple of tweakers the sheets
as long as my arm gas explosion at least
that's what they're calling what do you
call it cover-up below a third rib Close
Quarter technique exactly that was
taught right whatever it is whatever you
need same mud
same blood oh they're setting us up to
feel hurt right here pastel
not ready for it but I will be okay if
we end it is
please baby's in three we don't know
[Music]
how he's got the the exact right
apartment to see them observe everything
I mean he would pick that he's moved
somewhere he can still be inconspicuous
that's why he likes courtyards
it's a neat movie man they're like away
with the mystery of his character now
we're just looking at the soul of him
it's really cool yeah it's there's no
Discovery so it's a different thing it's
his I just expected like another action
like oh it's a seagull that should be
like cool action yeah
Vin Diesel can do this superpower too
and Fast and Furious very similar
franchise
Fook was so good at dread and like
making violence so palpably
uncomfortable next
right side he was right-handed why his
wife
his wife while he left-handed somebody
else was in that room
smart powder residue came from a latex
glove 20 000 Euros were found in the
Backpackers flat Susan was about to
figure out who was in that room that's
why she was killed Dave the two were
connected he's doing all the hard
figuring out edger is going to betray us
and I'm not gonna like it I mean he was
his partner for seven years you think he
would have the skill set to match figure
in his house right
yeah setting it up
don't kill miles just because he's late
to paint
yo man Elders closed oh
damn
maybe he does these things because oh
choreography is so good he's so cool
although you could tell it's really
Denzel doing it too yeah
oh do we'll dig because it's the sequel
two guns equalized but two guns oh also
two guns a boom comic book yes no you
got to spin the bin yeah kill your
brother
yeah you gotta go take care of that
tonight run down boss you can't be a
killer I'm gonna kill all these guys so
you don't kill
I'm the killer don't come back without
it empty
[__] let's go miles
let's go miles
you know him yeah he knows
taking control of the situation is it
what you want I thought you won the
Droid now what you said that [__] gonna
pay the [__] bills
you need to be a killer a little yummy
huh you need them
[__]
you know what they all did they liars
and so am I you know what happens when
you deal with a liar yeah
he's really teaching a lesson here you
got talent
you got a chance and I want to hear
about your environment what your mama
didn't give you and the white man won't
give you no shot you got a chance
use it while you're still alive
you don't know what death is
that was a great scene he's beat pushed
to the brink man kid is so good the
mentorship life guide and stuff and the
first one and some of the speeches like
they all had heart he's hit so much more
real
comfortable
it really is this ring so much more true
in all these scenes
exchange for the extra p
would you like something to drink yeah
come on it I bet Denzel personally
picked him I almost guarantee it yeah
what's she making
your mom's makes the same thing yeah
and this is not your house
you understand yeah
teacher matters
yo this is why I need a paint job see it
does I could do it for you could you how
much
I could get a plate of that food
115 right yeah
can you read chilihisi Coast between the
world and me all right you read that we
got a deal
oh man I don't know if I'd still read it
though that lack of judgment and can you
read man like so many great what up what
a beautiful movie here boy yeah this is
somebody's birthday
my daughter
uh-oh uh oh he knows
how did he specifically get him to pick
him up yeah the Uber riding thing I
guess you don't fly that often you've
been driving in the opposite direction
of Logan for the last three minutes
ah
[Music]
he's gonna take him out with one elbow
and a car it's all it takes someone eats
whoa these are great shots
[Applause]
[Music]
oh dude that was great that was a really
well done sequence that was so cool now
pick up your next Ride three minutes
away five stops
[Music]
man and you know who stuck that guy on
him
that first guy and Pedro past cage Roman
because he was getting onto him I know I
don't want to believe it
I love the build up of this storm yeah
we're gonna get some kind of cool
Crescendo aren't we more rain Denzel
the dentist gonna be the gardener grapes
what if he's a good guy no this is where
the movie tries to convince you it might
have
I Believe In You Pedro seriously baby
Pedro being a daddy again I think I
think Louie's trying to convince us the
archetype that he's going to betray him
I I'm team Pedro I'm back I'm back team
good guy honey the front doorbell is
broken your old army buddy was at the
back door for almost five minutes
actually I was his team leader seven
years I got the days mixed up this is
Robert McCall this is my wife Carol hi
he was waiting for something else
specifically
[Music]
um
let's go you all right yeah
he thought he was dead all right it's
working because I just love Peter Pascal
I took this
off the guy
who tried to kill me yesterday whoever
we're looking for made call for that
phone
what's he on the lookout for
[Music]
I wanted to believe
government shut us down
I went private right after
now there's a price next to them we
killed the enemy who said they were the
enemy
we just followed orders
it's fair it's fair no one knew the
Brussels contract was a deep agency
asset
Susan was going to figure out who was in
that dining room until you crawled out
of your grave
oh he revealed himself to her
to all of us all right Resnick Kovac all
of us oh wow gentlemen that's pretty
good for a dead guy
we all want you to know none of this is
uh personal
ity oh he found his equals
the mistake you made was you killed my
friend so
I'm gonna kill each and every one of you
and the only disappointment in it for me
is that I only get to do it once
his family's in the background I love
that Dave said you could give me a lift
to the uh station help and Company let's
go
see
help end company
okay
oh damn come on
oh you thought smiling I love it oh it's
so good I love it perfect I thought
equalizer 3 is coming later because this
might not have done well but I'm
beginning to think that's why because I
put a lot of thought into the movie yeah
like I had to reshape it to be something
special so thought like it's the way
it's executed is like really thought out
like this is a shorter run time but it
feels so much more patient there's so
much more Nuance to this franchise than
most
he knows how they move he knows what
they would do he was the leader
oh no I'm so worried your National crib
actually
oh you got any food around here I'm
starving
oh no
I was just some dude out here delivering
pizza
you really bought pizzas
this is making me hungry like the last
but different well we actually had pizza
boxes yeah
just in case for the weight
it's got to look good I'm like two extra
large pepperoni pizzas
for this marriage
no no I'm hungry
It's gotta hide the silence for two bro
miles listen to me real careful go to
the bedroom go to my bedroom you'll see
a bookshelf
what
you'll see a button behind it I want
you to push the button miles
that's cool I want to install one of
those I really want a safe house
bookcase yeah that's really cool
be quiet
don't worry
be quiet much quieter miles
yo man I don't do well in small spaces
H looking right at me don't worry about
it
this is scary it's so nice damn
you really don't want him to die
oh come on he might have prepared for
every detail
[__]
smart interrupt him interrupt him you
thought you could catch me here huh
huh
since you're in my house what are my
plans
smart yeah but he waited till the last
minute yeah you know where I'll be
[Music]
um yeah
huh
I don't know where he's headed I was
interesting rack Focus situation he's
going to the hardware store
Showdown where we must fight it's a Home
Depot story kid
I'd wait hours
I don't know why people in movies
I'd be like I'm gonna weigh like several
hours I'm gonna sleep here and then yeah
and wait till the morning
literally no reason to leave you should
oh
back up
dude should have stayed for a lot longer
that was
the one decision in this movie hey I
mean I it's it's because the kid's naive
and scared they set that out but still
yeah just got off a double shift just
gonna check and see if I left my gas on
all right make it quick let the great
BMW grow
th
oh I want to buy a BMW
I wonder where that came from
wow look at that wow beautiful done the
storm's it's bigger than I expected I
didn't know they go coastal with this
storm Zeus is going to throw lightning
bolts from the sky it's gonna become a
little crafty in Philippines so tense
that's a really suspenseful scene
what a beautiful last setting an
abandoned town and like the throes of
Madness in the mouth of Madness ah
Lovecraft who often had his work in
Massachusetts
that was his wife's Bakery
[Applause]
I think Pedro played this role great
yeah like it sometimes when you find out
someone's a villain there's like a total
switch but it feels like the same guy
and I bought the duplicitousness until
they had to make me believe like it was
great
again so much more use of environment
yeah and another great setting for the
finale instead of being inside they're
outside this time
still rain not yet but it'll come oh
yeah what an expensive set I know I feel
like the whole movie was like this is a
lot more simplified the way they did a
lot of this but then this this whole
sequence look this is really Thriller
money right yeah the weather environment
building insane
I got moved at 12 o'clock
locking down south side I love how
Denzel has hasn't even threaded to
release the information he's like I'm
just gonna kill you yep that's it that
is a good way to escalate the stakes in
the beginning show he's willing to give
her more nah no no no more
murder
there's a lot of cool locked off shots
in this one Anton Fuqua discovered GoPro
great sound design too with this setting
the eyeball lock off that's intense
oh hell yeah put his hand in there or
his face
fell for the old mirror trick push
towards the ocean
[Music]
cool this movie has surprised me so much
it's such a different tone Oh wow
oh
[__] whoa whoa whoa so you got all the
nerves oh whoa whoa Wicked povs
wow great shot
foreign
I got a blood trail looks like he's
headed across the main
to the bakery
you're gonna die up there dude
I love this aesthetic so much
it's like a video game fight it really
is
[Music]
come back
oh my god oh
God just me and you dating nobody's left
not exactly
I mean yeah I guess they're safer up
there I mean the kid's not with them
always have a contingency plan oh that's
right I totally forgot about him miles
there yeah so pulled into the Bowman I
wasn't even thinking ahead show yourself
and I won't kill the kid
oh great
the wood makes it interesting
tail light
oh did they actually get clipped time's
up man
oh it's smart damn he just had to like
glance at the hit him like [__] it he
just
the wind does make it interesting
Susan and you're not gonna save this
dude yourself oh [__] what the hell you
got up there
foreign
[Music]
oh
man the amount of nerves severing huh
the pain of that death yeah
but his lips
yeah he just cut him apart yeah
oh you did get slightly clipped yeah you
get clipped on that taillight trying to
think
oh is this his home oh yeah he
eventually did go back home yeah it went
in and out it's not bad my mom's just
gonna be pissed yo not at me man
that's true
you talked everything all right
we didn't see her what she looked like
huh in the first movie I don't think so
In Search of Lost Time the book's right
there
uh her glasses oh it was her last book
yeah it was back to the book it was her
copy come on sit down
they were meant to hand off the
franchise to miles that's what three is
yeah a young passing of the Baton
what are you drawing
working on a superhero character
what's Fountain he equalizes
those things before you do
so yes uh
secret rooms magic locks
back I appreciate that
Oh I thought she was gonna be like what
are you gonna call him
The Equalizer too it's Denzel Washington
wow
Robert painted all that
oh what about the old man yeah I think
that's got to be the ending or picking
up the guy at the airport but what's the
old man what's the paint
I leave you the best of myself with the
signature right there yeah I wonder if
the old man painted that
when I went on
if you could just give me a moment okay
oh my God he got it for him
oh wow oh that's even
crazier man
Sammy
oh
my God
what is this sequel this is a while
this is this movie really surprised me
man it's so different than any other
little genre this is this is like a
drama
this is a drama man
where is its paint on its sleeves man
[Music]
uh the two chairs I thought it was
beautifully let him sit there like that
moment for them
they apples
wow
not the movie I expected not at all
there's not even like
there's not even like callbacks to the
first one they don't do any of that like
sequel [__] other than you you know
characters that continue over if like
Bill Pullman and Melissa but there
there's no like winks and nods we don't
know how you know what's her name's
doing like it just it just moves
security guard guy from the first movie
yeah
oh yeah are you clear Grace from rats
you were talking about yeah they don't
they don't even bother with any no they
just like
yeah and they it really gets you like
invested in this this story that was
that was so surprised I was I I was so
surprised by just how different it was
the entire time and in a great way like
the first was more fun yeah
um but this like sucked me in into the
drama of it all the first one's like 70
John Wiki in action 20 drama ten percent
like Thriller this one was like 60 drama
20 Thriller 10 action and 10 I don't
even know what like there's a there's a
new thing here like it's very tense and
palpable pain
yeah there's there's like action
sequences if anything in the movie
segues into being more of what it wants
to be like it starts off
like the beginning of this movie is what
I thought the whole movie was gonna feel
like yeah yeah yeah the opening is like
more like the first movie yeah the
opening is eyes like look at him in a
disguise that he's he's equalizing yeah
jumping at this little girl like cool
and to remind you and it catches you up
and it puts you in the like this is what
the movie and then it just then it
transitions it's slowly but the
transition's quick once the killing
happens yeah then it changes genres as
soon as the same type of death because
we're both like oh they're good at the
villain it felt like they were just
setting up the new villain in the same
way yeah and then it changed immediately
and it never came back I thought we were
okay that guy's our villain of the movie
Let's uh we don't see him for another
hour let's see them fight each other
yeah I didn't even recognize him he
literally is the guy that got like his
stomach guts blown up but we didn't see
him again for an hour until after we had
the Pedro Willie won't they that was so
surprising I was I was really
emotionally caught up in that because it
was a bit of a
uh
uh we can recalibration I would say when
when it started introducing the subplots
and the different characters of okay
we're getting acquainted but this is
moving a little slower than I expected
and and then before I knew what I was
I'm really pulled into what they're
actually doing and even I think a real
switch that started to happen for me
earlier on because this movie is
transitioning into being I think that's
what they got right with the directing
and editing especially was we can't just
do this movie right away we as people
first we have to transition it and it
was when he killed the guys at the
um those Wall Street yeah yeah
because it wasn't the cathartic kind of
kill when he first kills the Russian
people in the first movie
use because in the when he first kills
the Russian people in the first movie
you're like wow this is freaking
surprising look how cool he is and in
this one it's it's like that scene but
instead what you get caught up in is
look how dark of a character he's
because yeah like he is just mer you
could feel the the darkness within him
like and then it was interesting The
Duality of that darkness of like murder
is bad with the joy of like how he's
cleaning up his town like him bopping
around in the beginning because he's
like found this purpose like when you
know he rescues the girl he sees her and
he like spins around that pole like
there's a there's a jubilance to him
knowing and then you see him in the act
of doing the killing how like dark that
is like how painful it is yeah and then
when Melissa Leo dies like that was a
that seems hard to watch I do like how
they
let her at least you know put up a good
fight oh yeah like that made sense for
the character and also you know what the
movie's saying but it was hard to see
you know a 95 pound older woman getting
broken down to these two you know big
guys and even even the choice of the
villain of just you're talking about one
of your favorite words Duality it's a
duality of man
uh but to make him
essentially another path that Robert
like you just want to call him Denzel
but essentially give another path that
Robert himself could have gone down
Robert himself could have reacted that
way as well and just been like I am an
assassin For Hire yeah instead of just
kills people who thinks we're doing bad
these are the Craigslist vigilance yeah
he is the Christ did not follow through
now it's all lift driver vigilante you
guys he's just doing all the day labor
jobs in California you got to do
different 1099s frankly I hope Denzel's
up on it I I do find the tone shift
interesting because I I not a lot of
sequels can change that much and still
feel like the franchise but it still
does yeah like I love when like alien to
aliens is the most prominent example I
think of like completely changing genres
and still working I'm really curious if
the third film is a different thing like
do you think it will still be a drama
Thriller pain experience
I don't know I haven't even seen the
trailer for it I don't know if there is
one is there one yeah that's what made
me go oh that's what made me ask you
about this okay I was that removed from
this whole like experience I was going
to cover it and then I was like I don't
even remember the first movie so I gotta
watch that oh you could watch that yeah
I'm like I don't know what I would say
and I don't want to read Wikipedia and
then I talk to you and you didn't watch
it so I was like oh man now I got an
excuse I'm so glad I never knew that was
a Boston Denzel movie because I would
have watched it and I wouldn't have had
this experience and now I can't wait for
a Boston tinsel free
do you know which one you liked more I
think I might like this one a little bit
more I think it would be like alien and
Aliens where I would watch it depending
on mood if I want an action thriller
that's smart I'm gonna watch the first
one if I want to watch a drama that
makes me very very tense and think about
dread I'ma watch this one they're
different animals
do you want a burger or pizza because
yeah what what I thought this movie also
did surprisingly really what I would
like for the third really quick when I
want to throw out there is what I would
like for the third one is he really
needs to have no pun intended he needs
to have an equal matched villain sure he
really needs that by this point someone
who can truly like he needs a Moriarty
yeah yeah and I I did find that both
villains the first one felt more of a
sequel but in his brutality and then
like he felt more of an equal till we
got to the finale right and then it was
suddenly like de-powered but there's
Pedro Pedro Pedro Pascal's character
um when he's up on that thing he gets
taken out by like wires and I was like
nah like it just without that happening
how would Denzel who's so calculated
have solve that problem well yeah I
thought that okay that bothered me a bit
these guys have been in the field
they've still been killing and they were
people of Denzel used to
um part of his past is connected to them
so I thought that okay this is going to
be a bit of a challenge and I mean yeah
it took a lot of calculation it was
still really tense like I love it that
was beautiful the whole setting of that
finale was great I loved it
um
that one part of me that I wish it had
was again
should have been a little bit harder for
him to this I I don't like that the big
bad was taken out by Nature first I
don't like that the variable wasn't in
his control because he's all that
control but that bothered me a little
bit that was such an idiotic that was an
idiotic maneuver for him to be up there
oh 100 yeah it was like and the area
kept him up there and yeah yeah like
that was that was his first downfall
speed yeah which was like that note like
I feel like he chose The High Ground too
because he's kind of a coward right yeah
like I'll be the one just died you just
sit up here you guys go get killed
you're like I know a couple you're gonna
go and they all go yeah yeah but like
the third Act is a very unique action
set piece like I can't even imagine
designing a hurricane Cape Cod like yeah
I can't imagine what that set was like I
can't imagine what it was like to have
all those variables and the way it was
shot was fascinating I thought it was I
thought that was brilliantly done I I do
wish we got a bit of a minor resolve for
Bill Pullman yeah we don't know it kind
of just that you dropped him off left
dropped him off from the hotel last time
we saw was just anguish yeah yeah and
like then moved on yeah because this
movie had more in its mind it was like a
sorrowful reflection it was the whole
story was like a grievance tale this
felt like uh the first one felt like a
Punisher movie and this one felt like
old man Frank like his last mission he's
like killing sucks but it's what I love
yeah it's interesting to get an
equalizer three because this feels like
a great ending for it especially for the
fact that he goes home it feels like
he's he he knows he has to do the
killing but we realize that it's not
cool to kill like it's not like a a
joyous thing and that's why I like to do
the duality of him being so joyous while
the killing was actually so painful yeah
so I don't know what the third one can
be because those are two very
resounding lessons yeah
I hope it's not just a fun action movie
especially after this as I thought this
one this becomes just a silly like I
thought it was gonna be like double the
action
yeah there's less action and and but
it's I would I really like the subplots
like I like the the characters in the
other one I like the subplots
um
but like when miles was in danger oh man
I was so I was on the edge of my seat
that Panic Room scene a lot I really
thought
it could go either way yeah I I believe
him getting killed because we liked him
enough that I was like they did that
scene right before where we endeared to
the guy yeah so they might kill him
because that's what you do you make him
you make it love the kid and then you
kill him so it like Denzel's got
Vengeance to write yeah the first one's
more clever in the sense of like what's
cool about both these movies is they
both have it by the Numbers kind of plot
yeah by the Numbers action plot it's
what makes them special is the way they
execute them and not just with its
action scenes but its overall
storytelling like when we watch first
equalizer as I I don't recall like how
great of a character this guy is written
yeah you know and in that movie you're
really witnessing him in the perspective
of how others witness him and this one
you're more in his POV yeah you live
with him as a character here yeah he's
less of a shark just causing things
yeah yeah yeah like that one you're like
look how cool he is yeah because it's
Denzel you're just like oh and you know
what by the end hair made it better
because like that made it a different
character
as did his hair I think the visual
difference of like him helped me like in
the first I think the opening him being
bald I think that was a subconscious
like this is a man that's changed true
yeah there it seems like there was a
deliberate choice right because he's
bald in the beginning of the Moon
equalizer one equalizer or was it just a
choice to show a passage of time of how
long he's been equalizing they didn't
really give us that though it didn't I
didn't care as it indicator it's clearly
been two to three months but like I
don't know how fast hair grows but like
clearly like it felt like a different
not character but characterization of
the character yeah
I wonder if he's bald in three and we'll
find out what kind of Mission Impossible
[__] is his hair long or short this time
what tone are we gonna get by Denzel's
hair either way I mean I know Denzel's
like the guy like I feel like when
people talk about the great actors it's
Denzel and this franchise shows how you
can make an action franchise way more
interesting by having someone that
powerful because the scene with him and
miles is like that scene in the in the
lobby right after the elevator is one of
the most beautiful scenes I've seen
about making a choice about which way
your life's gonna go and the way he
breaks him down the way he builds him
back up the way he then threatens him
the way he gives him power the way like
all of those moments and Dynamics in
like what four minutes that was
incredible acting from both of them that
wouldn't work with most actors and I
like how you can tell that part of what
propels him there is the pain that he's
feeling from the loss of his friend
right and now he's trying to save this
person you could tell that becomes a
thing where he just has to get involved
uh and he doesn't even have to say it
just like don't become like me it didn't
have to like look at my eyes is
everything he needs to say about like
what that world is yeah I was I was wild
I thought the gangsters would come back
in some way I liked that that that I
like that the movies that are in this
genre normally would have been that yeah
because yeah the first one's kind of by
their own response so is this yeah this
time it's more personal his friend died
yeah his old party he's got to go back
into and go back home and take out his
partner but yeah how do you deliver it
but how you deliver it is it in its
whole Ambiance like this entire mood was
was so different like I found myself
just we didn't talk at all yeah and that
you're welcome yes because the 2.5 is
just sucked in I don't know that's the
thing about scenes yeah this is gonna be
like a 30 minute watch because like we
were so in it I found I found myself
often like
because I think in the first one there
were times where I was like okay let's
go back to some of the action the first
one was fun to watch with someone
because it was like a party and this one
was hard to watch like I kept forgetting
I was on camera so it was hard to watch
on camera because I kept being like and
I kept forgetting to like do the thing
I'd like to make a comment right yeah
because it was hard to share it because
I was like
yeah that was I was sucked into that one
I was I'm really surprised by how how
transportative of an experience that was
I was very immersed in a very painful
way like I'm very tense I'm very
exhausted I'm very like uh affected by
the violence I I don't do well with
Ultraviolence I used to I used to love
like you know slashers and brutal
violent movies of like you know action
but the older I get the more uh it
affects me in a way that like I don't
like to put myself in that position I
don't like to like I don't want two
hours of pain that I can avoid and I
know that you know some people find
catharsis and horror and some people
find like enjoyment and brutal action
but there's something in me that like it
it's just putting myself in pain for
longer and like life's hard so it was
weird to watch that and be like I don't
want to
experience assault of people because why
and in a good way it was successful but
it made it so like yeah killing's bad
like I felt that it's what I like your
Punisher comparison though yeah because
my mind immediately went to but how did
koi enjoy Punisher uh so the first
season of Punisher I thought really
delivered on this is a man that only
knows pain so he has to inflict pain and
I think one of the things that I didn't
like about season two of Punisher was it
then became a man striking Vengeance as
Revenge without it being any sort of um
nothing seemed to impact his
emotionality he was just rage and that's
that's what I struggled with with John
Wick 3 compared to one two and four is
John Wick 3 like the Artistry of the gun
fu and the and the pain of it doesn't
feel like it's as important as the cool
and and so I like the violence of John
Wick movies because it's so removed from
reality it doesn't feel like I'm living
it but the thing these movies do is is I
feel like I watch someone get beaten to
death and I don't like that but it
that's the good of it succeeding yeah
yeah because the pun also the other
thing that came up with the Punisher
comparison was the fact that this
reflected on the the fact they're both
vets right you know and that we with the
way we treat vets and the way you can go
after because there is a a ticking clock
of usefulness to the government that
when it runs out is it private sector or
VA is it you know some of the homeless
people in La is it like and and that you
know it's a it's another cliche writing
action thing of like now I'm private and
it was delivered a bit more uh in a in a
painful way here it was delivered in a
way that's you know I have nothing left
this is my wife and kids like Denzel
just killed that guy's that wife's
husband and like you have to live that I
thought this was a kind of a bold way to
do a sequel I thought this was really
bold yeah because I bet if we put on the
trailer it would just be like a cool
it's the open movie yeah I bet they
would take a lot of these seeds just
make it look like it's just a bitching
movie isn't it look at him kicking ass
yeah and I don't feel like they would
communicate at all with the actual
feeling of this movie is and I have no
because of the sequel I have no idea
what the third one is as I remember like
I used to kind of follow Anton fuqua's
career a little bit better and I sort of
fell off the map a little bit obviously
I haven't seen freaking pleasure too so
um but you know like he did I didn't
know I did like the Replacement Killers
which was a cool action movie and all
would um which had a lot of drama but it
was like really for the action you watch
it and then they needed like training
day and
you know like equalizers I don't see any
of the training day in that no but here
I see the training day of this
collaboration of Denzel and and Tom
Fuqua like I could see that in here you
see why this is his first sequel like
you see what the pitch was that makes it
worth Denzel and Anthony you know when
people say we have to do a sequel if the
story is good and it matters and
justifies it a lot of times you're like
what a load of crap this was like no I
see it like they really had something
they wanted to tell and it feels like
honestly they made the first movie to
get to this one
and then we'll make ours you gotta get
that Vibe yeah because this felt way
more like what I'd expect from a Denzel
movie not like you know I I was I love
the first one but it's very much like we
got Denzel in an action movie so it's
gonna have more Nuance this one is like
there's a lot of nuance we've sprinkled
in some action yeah it felt more like
they LED I mean the first one still does
feel like Denzel you get like a
different side of density to get that
fatherly side of him I mean he is that
you get those fatherly qualities of
course you know with Chloe Grace
everyone else who's mentoring left and
right he's a life coach everywhere he
goes sure but this one they become a lot
more direct we're with him in Miles
where it's it's very much a parenting
yeah the first one felt like an uncle
this one felt like a dad yeah like an
uncle that's like coming in fixing stuff
giving you a lesson yeah this one's like
I gotta raise this kid's gonna sit in a
rocking chair and he's gonna listen to
me yeah this was so powerful I and
that's why when you ask that everyone
like better it's it's pizza or Burgers
it's it's they're different meals
they're different nourishments they're
different flavors equalize as much as
first one's much easier to put on 100
but this is the one I'm like all right
guys let's turn the lights off let's pay
attention this one's plated this is one
of those restaurants that plates their
food this one's got like fancy garnish
on it and it's still a really like good
meal but it's a lot more complicated and
then the first one's like I like pizza
two pizzas the gun on top because
there's no scene in here even with the
action there's no I I would probably
watch like the finale action back again
as like a study for sure it's a scene I
would just put on but like there's
scenes there's action scenes at the
first one where you're like I just want
to see this cool moment play that again
play that again whereas uh here even
even this some of the coolest part like
the the car chase scene that was so sick
it was so well crafted and a lot of
times car chase scenes
I'm not I normally don't really love a
lot of them sure I think a lot of times
they're like really choppy and they
don't feel that cool and you gotta find
you gotta find that right line and I
thought that was a really well edited
and shot uh car chase sequence that had
a really good Crescendo at the end and
even that was this is really suspenseful
it's not I'm not just watching look how
cool right yeah and I know he survives
but I still was in suspense like
obviously he doesn't stab him to death
like you know that the bad guy's gonna
lose it you're still invested they did
such a good job making it tense it's
funny how this movie is also 20 minutes
shorter because it feels it feels like
four hours but in a complimentary way it
feels it feels longer uh because it
really feels like it took its time and I
and I'm more exhausted like it feels
like I cannot describe how I feel I'm
very like flattened out by this movie
how was that two hours and two minutes
because I'm I'm wrecked yeah I mean yeah
that's a lot it's surprising how sure it
was into the across the spider versus
longest movie
that's funny when we saw across the
spider verse I remember watching it
going how long is this long I didn't
know the run time runtime 220. I did you
know it the first time we watched it
because I was really excited the first
time you watched it yeah I thought it
was like because the run time came out
and I was like whoa this is not the
movie that they I think they're
advertising and that gave me actually
more faith in it and then it delivered I
thought we were walking into a 90-minute
animated movie no so when it kept going
I was like wow this is really long but I
don't want it to end well because the
tone it's also like this one where it's
like we're gonna totally change the tone
of the movie actually oddly enough
spider-verse one to two is way more in
common with this than John Wick wanted
to do oh a thousand percent
I thought this would do what John Wayne
who did where is it spider verse like
better like cooler action scenes uh but
this was like now we're gonna we're
gonna zero in and just give you like
more characters yeah and uh and we're
gonna trust the pace to be ponderous and
like painful I really did like Pedro
Pascal's performance there is a number
in my head though that I kept having to
do every time you showed up on screen I
can never just see the character because
I'm so aware of Pedro Pascal and the
amount of freaking interviews I have
seen of him this year alone yep so many
interviews that I was so aware every
time he was on screen of what is younger
Pedro Pascal before he was Pedro Pascal
like how was this five years ago that
man has had some City miles put on him
in this press tour because he looks a
lot I don't know that's why it doesn't
return in the suit because it wore down
on him in Mandalore how much makeup was
on Peter Pascal to make him this young
in this movie and he's actually aging
better I think like he's aged in a way
that he's more ruggedly handsome he's
got one of those things where the salt
and pepper look and all that it totally
works better because you're right he
looked deep fake to a point I was like
who's this
cyborg paper Pascal a little strange
like I I the young one made me
uncomfortable yeah but like it's like
I've never seen super young Clint
Eastwood but
even then he looks like 40.
like he's always had a weathered face
because he's playing yeah imagine like a
wrinkle freak Clint Eastwood how weird
that would look
even Scott looks like 40 at Birth
they both have that like a son Scott
Eastwood from the fast movies oh
like they close they have that Sunday
no they have that thing where they just
have that like they get better and
better more weathered I feel like Pedro
Pascal has that yeah I definitely think
he has that I still was able to whenever
I move past those thoughts
I was still able to see the performance
for what it was and I thought he
actually did a really great job him and
Denzel read off each other very well
yeah that scene in the bench was great
the the win makes it interesting line
was delightful but even villain reveal
scene was done really well like I love
the way that was done I read I I like
how he doesn't just descend into
are we gonna get a monologue no we got
like this really cool scene in a kitchen
that felt like a scene in a kitchen it
felt like that's why I kept saying
fences this movie feels like a drama set
in houses and fences like it does that
Kingsman he also plays government man
who also betrays apparently mid-30s
Pedro face was government man and now
rugged Pedro in his late 30s 40s his
daddy man Daddy's doing the work and
this one he actually was a father and
yeah the guy plays Miles do you know the
actor's name I don't know his name but I
really like his work Kia he's amazing so
in in Wu-Tang in American Saga he plays
Rizza and I don't know how much you know
about Wu-Tang Clan but Rizza was one of
the most instrumental figures in hip-hop
where he was able to be a producer and
artist an actual rapper and basically
started the business and he combined
multiple sounds of like different styles
of hip-hop from like Staten Island and
Brooklyn and all these different places
and he was one of the original MCS that
mixed sounds from like other mediums so
he was like Gathering uh dialogue scenes
from like uh you know Kung Fu movies and
putting it over like beats and all these
things yeah and yeah so that's what the
actor needs to be able to do is be
someone convincing of like I'm gonna
make everything work with all of these
disparate parts and make it seem like I
can deliver all that while also being a
guy that runs a crew that's 12 people
strong and why it's important so he's
got like that job as an actor is
impossible to be like I'm this you know
10 things that Rizza is but also be so
charismatic that it's not a boring
Exposition dumb and to be able to keep
up Denzel you know I don't know how old
dude is but like what an incredible
force of a 20 something
I do want to look I I feel because you
always hear those stories about Denzel
where he like brings people under his
wing yeah I mean he got Chadwick start
yes as one example of yeah of Ted zelp
being like as I'm sure the guy probably
had to screen test with Denzel
um but let's see if there's some like
facts on it um because I also want
another dude's name because he he's
great I would like to know he's skinny
but I think if he bumped up he'd be such
a good Bishop 6.7 oh people went into
this thing and they'd get an action
movie
oh yeah I could totally see where people
would be disappointed with it Orson Bean
is it the light you passed uh Ashton
Sanders yeah Ashton Sanders okay that's
actually it's a pretty easy name to
remember Ashton Sanders is on his third
build on the uh Little Stars list there
well deserved uh I think an American
Saga is one of the best shows that not
enough people are talking about it just
finished its three season run it wrapped
yeah it was his first sequel yep good
call
uh okay
hold on
they want the fight seems to be as
realistic as possible Tyrone Woodley
trained Denzel that's cool as hell I
love that Target Woodley's fantastic the
sequelizer that's funny
uh okay
come on I'm trying to find that one fact
but I'm finding myself like wanting to
read all the facts yeah Donald Cerrone
trained two man Cowboys one of my
favorite Fighters
I love that two UFC fighters maybe more
helped Denzel get even more badass
[Music]
oh this is all the tax credits in Boston
that makes sense okay I just want to
look up how this guy you could look up
like it might be easier Google like
Ashton Ashton Sanders and Denzel
Washington
Denzel Washington
it's got to be like something here it's
like look they're like interviews
together for promoting the movie yeah
have they been into other stuff together
oh he oh I didn't realize I haven't seen
Moonlight yet I didn't realize he was in
it is he yeah it just said Moonlight
Breakout
Moonlight breakout Ashton Sanders
continue to have their surrogate
father-son relationship
for sure for the movie moonlight uh it
says Moonlight breakout oh we're holding
the moon my star is like a phrase oh no
like moonlights and quotes
uh yeah they're doing these interviews
together
come on give me a fact just give me a
fact exploration of the surrogate
father-son relationship
uh in the script who also wrote helped
the bones were there hadn't met Ashton
yet and the idea was good he said you
know the mentor mentee relationship only
gurus we got to know each other that
became a conversation between takes it
was natural because I have two sons and
he was like my third son
so it doesn't sound like he actually
brought him on
if you didn't know him before I was like
you knew him before he's up but he said
uh
he said wait didn't I just really didn't
I hadn't met Ashton yet ah
oh wow which surprises me because their
their relationship was incredible
that's cool okay so you see how Ashton
Sanders got his start yeah because like
this is gonna be 20 minutes of my coin I
just reading just like how would you
like to watch us read uh
continuous people relate to
um yeah no this guy's like so good
all right that's sweet guys well what
did you think about The Equalizer too
guys do you think it's better than the
first
do we avoid the trailer for three
it's already out right yeah the yes
we've gotten this far
right like is it unless it plays in
front of the movie in the next like week
in theaters it's gonna be out of the
trailer rotation yeah you're right I
mean what if there's a trailer too we
could react to it for people that watch
these and then like have that but then
we'd know too much I don't know if I won
because trailer two is their story I
don't know if I want to see a trailer I
I I'll avoid it'd be pretty cool to
avoid the trailer and just go in like
who's the Pedro and David Harbor of the
third one
like who's that actor that we're like oh
my God
I did have one thing spoiled for me of
who's in it oh okay
um this is not not the villain but a
if you manage to avoid this information
that would be awesome I will try
is it Bill Burr no good it'll make you'd
laugh for sure
I don't want to say anything okay but I
mean it's set in Boston it's gonna make
sure found out and I was like really
that of course gonna flap laugh at this
I mean I hope Ash and Sanders is in it
kid's great guy I haven't looked up at
any of the cast no no I found out who
one of the cast members was and I was
like oh that's cool I'm like oh and I
was like oh that's so funny
I'm so curious now Isaiah you all know
why when you when I when I find out yeah
is it something that uh when does it
come out September yeah yeah so we will
probably get it like November
October it's a 45 day window oh is that
the thing that's what it all is how I
map out my okay let's reacting so late
it's 45 days from when Transformers
comes
so we could do yeah we'll have an
October uh movie to look forward to in
the dry season
there's no dry season here
[Laughter]
uh this was so different than I expected
uh I'm really happy we just like had
that I think craving hundreds out in
October though uh and and I'm so glad it
was so different because we spent the
whole time like silently wondering what
this movie was in such a good way
um I'm curious what the overall
consensus though unfavorite is because
they're two different movies like yeah
well let me know in the comments which
which of the two you like and why
well
we'll see you guys in October that's
when koi will finally return to the
channel that's it not until then not for
all the things we're doing between now
and then that's then attraction two
secret Invasion also I mean like in this
in this series in the movie series yeah
that's right and also of course comic
Conor and trailers I'll be here and the
minions obviously that's a great
extraction great journey next day
Brewing it up just having a time let's
just I think there's no Steve Carell in
that one I think let's just have more
feeling
oh man could you imagine just the sounds
and not like an actor to Anchor it how
maddening that would be no thank you I
think we should just really have just
constant just pure chaos pure chaos and
no smoothness in what we choose just
totally left field next we should watch
like a very intense drama that's not fun
to watch us watch
like a three hour like Oscar Bait film
that's like really dry all right guys
after watching extraction two we are
doing the English patients
I hear it's a fun one you know it's
gonna be a romp a real good time
alrighty guys
peace out reject Nation
[Music]